l'enseignant victime doit je l'ai dit
signaler l'ffet à sa
hiérarchie je l'ai dit trois fois pardon
je je mais évidemment si on signale rien
on peut rien faire c'est une évidence
bon la hiérarchie informe alors
l'enseignant de son droit de déposer
plainte et d'être
accompagné dans sa démarche par la
direction du service départemental de
l'Éducation
nationale la plainte doit être prise par
un policier ou un gendarme référent et
cette notion de gendarme
policier parquetier
référent c'est une notion importante
parce que ça implique des
facto une spécialisation et et et
comment
dirais-je une une attention particulière
que l'on va porter bien sûr à à la
situation l'enseignant est ensuite
orienté vers l'association locale d'aide
aux
victimes lorsque la protection de
l'enseignant apparaît nécessaire je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure sa
domiciliation devient le le l'école ou
le commissariat ou la gendarmerie pour
j'allais dire le mieux protégé bon
euh voilà ce que ce qui a été mis en
place l'idée vous avez compris c'est que
un de ces faits ne se perde et que l'on
puisse intervenir bon les agents de
l'éducation nationale disposent par
ailleurs d'un dispositif spécifique ils
disposent de la protection fonctionnelle
évidemment mise en œuvre par leur
administration et à ce titre encore ils
sont orientés conseillés et guidés et à
cela vient s'ajouter la prise en charge
qui est offerte à toutes les victimes
d'une infraction possibilité d'être
accompagné tout au long de la procédure
pénale
par une association d'aide aux victimes
susceptible de leur apporter un concours
juridique une assistance sociale
psychologique et un premier contact
pouvant se faire notamment via les
bureaux d'aide aux victimes situés dans
les tribunaux judiciaaires enfin pour
être complet la protection fonctionnelle
est une question qui relève de la
compétence du ministre et du ministère
de l'Éducation nationale mais les
recteurs doivent mettre en œuvre à
chaque fois que cela nécessaire la
protection juridique qui est prévue par
une loi du 13 juillet
1983 qui précise que la collectivité
publique est tenue de protéger les
fonctionnaires contre les menaces
violences injur diffamation outrage dont
ils pourrai être les victimes à
l'occasion de leur fonction et de
réparer le cas échéant le préjudice qui
en
résulte